activating Dominator portable
psychological diagnosis and suppression
system Dominator now online here we go
the operations underway
the overseas investigation divisions
field Circle team known as the peace
breakers for short since they're
currently hiding in Japan this will be
our best chance to put them down for
good
the research is collectively known as
the stronskaya papers in theory her
models predict what affects the Civil
system would have on the rest of the
world why did you really come back to
Japan would you have come back if I'd
invited you instead why is this so
important to tournament must be part of
a bigger plan both Justice and Truth
have many sides some things you can't
understand unless you're looking down
from a high but even if that's true I
believe in you because you want to do
what's right try to stay focused on your
next steps that's my advice
[Music]
the leader the promised land whenever a
human rules over another human there
will always be those murdered unjustly
the dominators have gone down and we're
facing heavy enemy fires we could take
over from here get to tsunamori
mankind created an all-powerful Garden
ninja civil but it is also man who now
attempts to kill that God give up the
law will judge you now
hey